and you wind welcome to zero filling
paradox from South Africa is right yes k
paradox Italian game this is a sideline
but it's a quite playable for black that
early d6 is designed to avoid the gambit
with 54 ok hmm can also castle here but
I'm not quite sure yeah king of age six
white cannot win a pony with d takes d
takes Knight takes Knight XD takes it's
not not an issue mmm I've got a soft
spot for attacking this kind of thing
with g5 but probably this isn't a good
idea here I can try to be flexible maybe
I cannot maybe I can delay castling for
a while and still have this option oh
that's a surprising move ok and don't
see that too often giving up the tension
in the center and giving me that nice
diagonal and maybe we'll play we should
be three to trade off this Bishop
very tempted to play g5 now or in the
near future let's say can also just
bring a night over here I think I'll do
that start with this if you are from the
plane I'd everyone to g3 no twin a4
cooney Forza surprising move pinning the
night simply pinning hmm maybe I hmm
king of eight and so on yeah maybe this
one for Knight f6 and neither for good
good move i guess trading trading this
off yeah ever ticket tonight we'll take
okay still probably correct okay so i
can try g4 here try to open up
immediately or she ate the g8 first
quite surprising g4 before is also
hanging almost now the queen is
protecting its toll
yeah it looks very dangerous for white
to put it mildly okay Wow check this
must be some kind of checkmate check
checkmate there is a checkmate now it
was dangerous I think her white I mean
here he should be so kind of okay i mean
i don't think that what can be worse him
but he has to be has to be alert because
im mean I've got quite a number of
pieces involved here on the kingside g8
yeah this is more or less losing I think
night h2 is what he has to do is also
given by the computer right a form and
its computer is on equal which is I mean
maybe but computers sometimes need a
little bit more depth to understand that
this kind of attack that is slowly
creeping forward is actually very
dangerous the engine gives this move and
this does this and that really equal
yeah maybe it is but I mean everyone I'm
attacking yeah so I'm rather I rather be
Blacky in this position computer wants
to play this this and this which is not
very natural this check this is good
because he's got this truck here
mmm very tough position I want to
quickly say something about the opening
castles is an interesting move on and
one idea said after Knight f6 right has
this option to play the form which
objectively speaking is not that great
but I don't know it well and I tend to
play d6 to avoid this default together
because now the night can take without
any any problem at all so C 3 and now
before the point is that this is not
winning any material if we look at this
check here black is totally fine after
who gave aid and he gets the pawn back
this is that way it continues with black
being a little bit more active it is
difficult to win here because of the
simplified nature of the position with
black is totally fine yeah yeah this is
equal ish d5 is surprising move I mean
he all of a sudden opens my diagonally
end and releases the central tension now
it I mean it was okay probably was okay
and how he played it maybe I could have
taken you for here this is a quite nice
spot there for the night yeah probably i
could have done that yeah now we had the
position that we looked at after after
this i think black is probably winning
yeah the engine is on minus two so it
doesn't doesn't see a defense here 965
also was winning but this is also strong
it threatens to take on 83 and threatens
to tear play g3 I also could have taken
is directly aiming for this
you know so tap too much okay thanks for
watching